it appears that britney has broken her
silence over the explosive new
documentary about her life
framing britney spears yeah you know she
was not interviewed for the film and now
there is something important that britt
wants you to know
you met phone i hold that damn phone
with you no daddy
is this britney's way of sending her dad
a message after the doc
posting this 2017 performance of toxic
with the message
each person has their story and their
take on other people's stories
remember no matter what we think we know
about a person's life
it is nothing compared to the actual
person living behind the lens
who decides if we're gonna post this
we're just gonna work out she does
as for her boyfriend's war with her dad
a source tells e.t
brit's team is surprised sam asgari
vocalized his feelings in the way he did
sam has always played ball and followed
jaime's lead but he's finally hit a
breaking point
this comes after sam called jamie an
expletive in a fiery post
claiming he is quote trying to control
sam's relationship with his daughter
if i wasn't under the restraints that
i'm under right now i feel so liberated
when i tell them the way i feel it's
like they hear me but they really not
listening
i'm sad we're told the documentary may
have pushed sam to finally speak out
our source claims jamie has never
treated sam as an ally which is
backfired on his relationship with his
daughter
my dad's a little crazy like that does
he own a gun
he does oh my god in 2013 the pop star
joked with e.t
about her dad being overprotective while
she was with then-boyfriend
david lucado does david and your father
get along yeah they get along
[Music]
tomorrow spears case is back in court
we're told
while sam wants britney to finally be
free of the conservatorship
jamie worries about her well-being i
just want to be a happy person
it's really important just to spread joy
you know and
be a happy person as for her ex k fed
his powerhouse attorney mark vinson
kaplan tells e.t
kevin's unsure if a conservatorship is
necessary but feels it helps their kids
because
it's always an extra layer of security
to maintain structure and stability
you